YouTube what up breaking up the cadence
of our normal content just wanted to say
thank you so much for all the support
over the last couple years to rock when
did we start getting serious over the
last three years you know if you look
back you know obviously if you go back
to and look and search right now my Wine
Library TV episodes you can see that
they don't have a whole lot of views
even though it's a big deal it's cuz I
moved to bitter hav alright just wanted
to quickly say what's up to everybody
thank you so much for subscribing for
being a part of this real quick if
they're seeing pre-rolls before my own
videos that means you don't subscribe
right the IROC if people a bunch of you
are making comments that you're seeing
pre-rolls that's because you haven't
subscribed you're seeing a pre-roll
before my own video on youtube because
you haven't subscribed so please
subscribe but besides that you know just
thinking a lot about accountability
about kindness thinking a ton about
using the new cycle everybody's scared
about Facebook and the Cambridge
analytical stuff using using that as an
advantage because I'm running a ton more
ads on that India as a market on
Facebook and Instagram is a huge
arbitrage little fun note there run some
ads on there you'll do well pay
attention to what I'm doing on Instagram
gifts if you're looking at my stories
you can see my swipe up gift go into
Instagram right now and type in the hit
the gift app and and type in Gary Vee
check out what I'm doing there and the
reason I'm saying that is and I'm gonna
say this and I need you to understand
this my friends a lot of people like
Gary is always motivating or giving me
mindset mental strategies but like what
about details so here are the details
the details aren't watch what I'm doing
watch what I'm doing why am I even
making this YouTube video in this format
today always pay attention to my actions
my entire strategy for bringing new
values predicates on the following I'm
gonna work on the operating system first
which is your mindset being optimistic
be
practical not being entitled all these
kids are hyped with me because they're
like I'm like already there ta'rhonda
can you just say hello real quick and
say I'm coming hello hello hey everyone
guys just gonna be like 90 seconds we'll
be right back on no worried thanks guys
I think two minutes is 120 seconds Tyler
thinks is 90 seconds anyway real quick
my arms getting tired
- it hit arms today real quick wasn't it
the actions just do me a [ __ ] favor
watch what I'm doing like why do I put
out content LinkedIn why am i all in on
my podcast my pockets is moving up I
don't know if you guys are noticing like
why why why why why why why why why why
why why why why why if you watch my
actions why am i running pre-rolls on
youtube why am I putting out more audio
clip form why am i doing more content
that makes you DoubleTap the Instagram
post I actually think I'm giving the
best how-to advice I just don't think
I'm making a video and doing the
[ __ ] [ __ ] this stuff right like
like drawing on the whiteboard and
saying like X - to see like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like meaning it's not [ __ ]
like cool I get it and there's tons of
how-to but oh by the way where's my
report card is there just anyway you
know to me there's a reason why I don't
make how-to videos it's the same reason
that this right look at this [ __ ] on
the floor card I'm not gonna couch you
[ __ ] because I don't like to do how to
[ __ ] it's the same reason I don't write
long emails and [ __ ] like that it's not
how I roll
I'm doing the best how-to content on the
[ __ ] Internet if you actually spend
your time watching what I'm doing and
why I'm doing it and if I'm consistently
doing it it means it [ __ ] works and
if you see me try something and you
don't see me doing it that much more
over the next 30 to 60 to 90 days
that means it didn't work test and learn
execute watch my [ __ ] actions work
I've been working this down job for many
night back and forth to the Costco I
gotta cut it out yeah they don't wanna
shut it